hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar applied biosystems hackpass
coded 19 combo kit a highly sensitive
specific
and robust real-time pcr test
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
thermo fisher to learn more visit
www.thermarfishers.com
so let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions
as you can to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box
and click send if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain
your credit i now present today's
speakers
lauren mikulski senior director in the
product manager
management genetic science division
clinical solutions at thermo fisher
scientific
dr vijay singh managing principal
scientist
for molecular diagnostics at health
track rx
and dr andrew brooks professor of
genetics
records university aku rucdr
infinite biologics dso
brooks life sciences for a complete
biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome to all of you lauren you may now
begin your presentation
good morning and good afternoon my name
is lauren mikulski i'll be speaking
today on the applied biosystems takpath
kova 19 combo kit i'm excited to discuss
the solution for detection of sars code
2 v2
the virus that causes cova 19 from
patient samples
using gold standard real-time pcr
technology
when we started looking at this when the
coronavirus outbreak began
in late 2019 thermo fisher scientific
rapidly developed one of the first covet
19 diagnostic tests
which is now scaling to manufacture 20
million tests per week
general fisher has scaled with the kobe
19 global crisis
and has been able to provide consumables
reagents
instruments and software to customers
around the world
thermal fissure is working to apply its
scale as a world leader in serving
science
to standardize and industrialize the
manufacture of tests and testing
platforms
in a reliable and reproducible way to
support the global need for testing at
scale
as you can see here on the slide
globally over half of all proven 19
testing is currently being performed on
some of the most
used real-time pcr instruments in the
world
we have rapidly increased our production
of cobia 19 kits
and continue to increase our
manufacturing as needed in preparation
for the next respiratory season
as you've heard in the news or maybe
experienced yourself
laboratories have been constrained with
supplies from reagents consumables and
instruments
thermofisher provides the end-to-end
supply for your laboratory workflow
to ensure there are no concerns in your
workflow and throughput
for cobia 19 testing it has been
critical to be vertically integrated
we are a single supplier and distributor
for consumables
reagents instrument software and
world-class service and support for
laboratories running
or looking to run covay 19 testing so
when we think about partnering
with thermo-fisher we really think about
being a leading supply chain
world-class laboratory service and
support and providing that
end-to-end covid19 workflow
our assay is used globally as part of a
cibd
kit a us eua combo kit and as a
component of many approved clinical
laboratory workflows
i will show you how the assay is
performing in our approved workflow and
later
vijay singh and dr brooks will take us
through how to performing
when at the center of other approved
workflows
overall the tacpas cova 19 assays design
and chemistry consistently delivers
highly specific and sensitive results
applied biosystems tacpas cova 19 kit
delivers a high throughput highly
sensitive and specific multiplex
solution
with expanding approvals for instruments
software and streamlined sample prep
clinical laboratories can now analyze
patient specimens collected
through six different methods as you can
see here on the slide
new sample prep protocol options deliver
a 20
reduction in plastic by reducing the
number of wash steps
and the sample input from 400
microliters to 200 microliters
allowing double the amount of purified
rna
the applied bile systems taxpath cova 19
combo kit is now approved for use
on all 7 500 systems the quant studio 5
96 well 0.1 and 0.2 milliliter
and 384 well blocks and the font studio
7 384 well block
and then lastly on analysis and report
the new applied biosystems cova 19
interpretive software helps your lab
decrease analysis
and interpretation time and eliminate
subjective interpretation by
automatically interpreting the data
results from the combo kit reducing risk
of user interpretation error
you'll see here as we talk about the six
approved sample inputs
one of the biggest bottlenecks in
testing people for the novel
coronavirus is around the shortage of
swabs to take samples
the fda announced that it would allow a
broader range of swabs to be used in
tests
including some made of polyester that
should be far easier to manufacture
and these have subsequently been
approved for manufacturers who have data
that have
seemed sufficient for extended approvals
we now have six different methods that
can be used for our kit
the main difference for this is really
how far the swab is inserted as you can
see in the diagram
next we'll go into specifically how the
assay was designed the combo assay
includes
three assays targeting regions of the
stars code b2 regions
with low genetic mutation risk orf1ab
and the snn protein genes that have
ongoing high sensitivity
the assay was intentionally designed
specific to star's pov2 genome
that are not present in other
coronaviruses such as stars
mers and bat stars like coronavirus
meaning
our athlete will retain higher
specificity than assays that target
other
mutations
a clinical evaluation was performed to
evaluate the performance attack
path covid 19 kit using nasal pharyngeal
swab and broccoli avira lavage
specimens a total of 60 contrived
positive specimens were tested
30 positive np and 30 positive ball
specimens
in addition to the contrived positive
specimens 60 negative specimens were
tested
in our studies we have observed no
measurable impact on sensitivity or
specificity
in the presence of common interfering
substances such as nasal administered
drugs
blood h1n1 and other allergy types of
medications
here we're showing the lod concordance
across all
96 well instruments nasal pharyngeal
swab specimens were spiked into purified
full length stars co-v2 viral rna
at 3x and 1x log level
the lod of 10 gce per reaction or
genomic copy equivalent
for the combo kit was achieved using all
96 well instruments
in addition an lsd of 10 gce per
reaction was achieved using both quant
studio 5
and quant studio 7 384 blocks
lastly i want to show you in terms of
our performance data was a
fine study that was recently released
find it stands for foundation for
innovation new diagnostics it's a global
nonprofit organization
that helps deliver diagnostics to combat
major diseases affecting the world's
poorest population
and as a partner institution to the who
fine performed an independent evaluation
of commercial kit performance conducted
at university hospitals of geneva
the primary objective was to verify
claims analytical sensitivity or lod
using contri specimens and the secondary
objective was to determine
diagnostic accuracy using previously
characterized clinical respiratory
samples
they used 50 positive and 100 negatives
the tacpac
coven 19 cibd rt pcr kit achieves
excellent results of lod one to ten
copies per reaction with a hundred
percent sensitivity
and a hundred percent specificity we
thank fine for including us
into the study
next i'll go into the workflow it's my
last slide just to cover
some of the questions that we've been
receiving in terms of throughput
one on every 96 well plate you can
analyze
94 specimens for cobia 19 in under three
hours
on every 384 weld plate either on the
quant studio 5 or quant studio 7 384
well block
you can analyze 382 specimens for cloven
19
in under six and a half hours we see
that
one kingfisher flex instrument can feed
either 296 well block
or one 384 well block instrument as seen
on this slide
with two full-time uh employees working
simultaneously
you can achieve a workflow to analyze
2820 specimens
in one 24-hour shift for laboratories
who can scale with technicians in
laboratory space
with four kingfisher flex instruments
and two 384 well instruments
and simultaneously the workflow can even
go up to over 12 000 specimens in a
24-hour shift
to help minimize instrument downtime
during this challenging time regardless
of contract status
we are expanding access to our augmented
reality and desktop remote support tools
to all applied biosystems in vitrogen
and ion torrent instrument customers
we've heard the uprise of the need for a
high throughput solution to assist to
get back to work programs and reopening
of school campuses
we've also seen the demand of testing
increase as infrastructure has scaled
and reimbursement has increased in
response we are developing a kobit 19
high 2-fit solution
to provide and allow for customers to
scale with ease without the burden of
considering how to track samples
write scripts and protocols or
integration into their limbs
so no matter the workflow or situation
our assay is put in
you'll see that it's consistently
delivering high specific
and sensitive results so i just want to
thank everyone for
listening on the chat and lastly we're
continuing to scale
both our testing manufacturing and
expanding our approved workflow
to enable more laboratories to perform
cobin 19 testing
with new sample inputs like saliva and
high throughput instruments to assist
with back to work and back to school
programs to increase capacity
thank you for the time and i'll pass the
presentation on to vijay singh who
who will speak to his development on the
quant studio 12k
flats
thank you lauren and um so yeah i'll be
talking today about our experience here
at healthtrack products and
very quickly developing and
incorporating a covert 19 diagnostic
test using the tack path kit and
incorporating it basically into our
existing workflow
while pursuing an emergency use
authorization
for the lab from the fda
so healthtrack rx we are a clinical
solutions company working primarily in
the fields
of infectious disease testing and
toxicology and we're located in denton
texas
right outside dallas now some of these
next slides they're sort of covered by
lauren and uh
we are inundated by all the news so
sarskoff ii
responsible for the covert 19 disease or
pandemic that we
the world is reeling under right now
it's a novel coronavirus and
if you look at the genomic makeup it's
very very similar
to the known coronaviruses especially
sars and mers
and
i'm not going to go into the next few
slides into the great details about the
epidemiology of the
disease and the details of the pandemic
and
how it is affecting life in general
and i'll start talking directly about
how we developed a test so what defines
a good diagnostic test or any diagnostic
test
but especially a clinical one
so here are some of the features one the
test should be relevant
right to the you know to the patient
condition
and it should be the results from that
test
it should have a positive impact on any
of the clinical decisions that are being
made with respect to patient care right
the test should be
rapid so you can have a great test
with a with a very dismal turnaround
time and
ultimately it would have no clinical
relevance and lastly
a good diagnostic test should be
reliable
right at all points the data that is
being generated
one should be able to put complete trust
into that and you know features like
low false positives and low false
negatives
and as we go through i'll be talking
about how the attack path covered 19
assay or the kit fits all of these
criteria and why we
ultimately adapted it in our testing
line
so
it was somewhere towards the end of
february
early march this year when we decided to
start testing
for uh covet 19
and what we started with was
one of the commercially available cdc
tests so the cdc
test covers only the n gene of uh the
sars cop2
and with n1 and n2 two different targets
within the gene
and the n3 was rejected for various
reasons
and what we immediately found was that
the
tests were not performing you know
consistently
the end with respect to n1 and n2 and we
would see different results
even though both the targets reside
within the same gene
and uh as we were performing these
validations
within a week the singleplex stackpath
assay covering the orf1a n
and s gene came out so we naturally
gravitated towards that because now we
are talking about
three separate targets within the genome
and so automatically that
is a good test highly specific for a
single target
and here at healthtrack we have a
very vast experience in using the
uh the high throughput nanofluidic
platform the
open array on the 12k flex but
those are for our infectious disease
testing and those are really
large panel tests and
we hadn't really performed any single
pathogen single target test
but we were interested in that and what
we found was that
the the singleplex stackpath assay was
uh
was highly consistent in the results
that we were getting
and as we were readying our eua
application to the fda with that
thermofisher came out with the multiplex
attack path covered 19 assay and
one can immediately see how that would
impact the
the turnaround time and uh you know the
high throughput capabilities
so we changed course again and we
decided to follow that
for our eua application and uh
ultimately and i'll give you some
details for that as we go forward
so it was april 24th that the
fda granted the ewa to our lab
at healthtrack and since launching the
test
we have performed successfully over 220
000 code 19 tests
so how is the uh eua granted to us
different it's in the sense that uh
you know we have uh it's it was
technically a bridging study
or a bridging experiment in that our
extraction methodology
and uh the the testing platform the
machine that we were using
are different from uh what was approved
by
the cdc or what was performed by the cdc
and approved by the fda
so after sample collection our total rna
extraction
is on a hamilton nimbus or a hamilton
star
fully automated system and the
actual real-time pcr is being performed
on the quant studio 12k flex system
equipped with a 96 well
block and that is
for what the data was submitted and the
eua granted to us so getting into the
details of
what i showed you the three properties
of a good diagnostic test
and how the
stack path kit follows that for us right
that the
good diagnostic test is relevant and
right now when almost all of the states
have lifted up
their lockdown measures uh
this test is more relevant than ever and
uh not just the recent reports in the
news uh
what we have noticed is that there is a
definite
uptick in uh the number of positive
cases and
this surge as the schools should open
towards the end of summer
people need to get back to work there is
an
absolute need to
you know have the people and the
students reintroduced back to their work
their school you know economic
activities educational activities in
in a safe and a reliable manner and so
there
is no more
not no more there is no more important
time than this
to have you know a test
for this virus
how is this test rapid now
we have tested both the singleplex and
the multiplex versions of this kit
and what this gives you is an absolute
ability
depending on the availability of the
nucleic acid to perform 94
individual tests every hour
and you know compared to
the the cdc kit that is available out
there through various
commercial vendors it allows you only 30
uh individual samples to be tested
at any given point and so the
the rapid nature and again i'll i'll
briefly touch upon
uh the 384 well format also and
that just you know gives you four times
the capability
so how was this test uh reliable
what we found was that the
trackpad kit or assay was highly
sensitive
and in fact you can see in the data here
we validated it right down to 10 raised
to power 0.1
rna copies per microliter
these tests were performed by spiking
sputum samples with the
positive control rna from the starscop2
and we decided to go with the sputum for
this
round was because sputum can be an
extremely
it can be a particularly difficult
matrix to work with but what you see
here is that we find very good linear
correlation
uh with 100 detection range
and we in fact we also tested
right down to 0.025 copies and uh
with about 95 detection range
and our very first five positive five
negative samples
we had an interla
correlation to test for that there was
another lab that
sent us those five positive and five
negative samples and we tested them out
in a blind fashion
and again a hundred percent correlation
we were able to detect
that the correct positive and the
correct negative samples
and since then we have done the same
for at least four different laboratories
out there
we are highly confident in the data that
is being generated
and the results that we are seeing uh
at the same time while we were
validating the test
we also did
a test for the specificity of the
assay and we looked at
previously known positive samples for
a number of respiratory viral and
bacterial pathogens
and which basically contribute now this
is the list
that is in front of you is the data that
was submitted to the
to the fda uh we tested
a few more uh
pathogen positive samples later and we
found
that the the tax path kit or the assay
does
not cross react with any of these known
positive
uh or respiratory pathogens
and that increased our confidence
with the test uh another
uh example of how
sensitive the test is uh while we were
uh
you know developing strategies to
[Music]
have the covet 19 testing uh we were
looking at uh
different extraction strategies
and in one of that what we did was that
we started diluting the
samples to look at the sensitivity of
the test and
the results are in front of you one of
the uh
positive samples uh we started diluting
the same one is to five one is to ten
i write up to one is to 50 and the
results are in front of you the
tax path covered 19 assay was extremely
sensitive so even up to the 150th
dilution
we got great signal and
the next one is uh it's quite an
interesting example of uh
how sensitive this test is so we had
reported out
a sample as positive and
about two or three days later
uh the doctor's office calls us saying
that uh
you know the patient had actually
submitted
their sample a week before it came to us
to another lab and uh
you know a big lab that had a very
very disheartening turnaround time of
you know nearly 10 to 14 days
and so that's why they didn't have the
results they were not feeling very well
and that is why they had sent the
samples to us their sample from the
other lab came back
as negative right and so they were
basically contesting our
results and i really cannot explain
these results
so what we did was we knew that they
were using the
n1n2 assay from the cbc kit
and uh so what we did was that
we performed the test in parallel using
the
commercially available pvc kit and
the attack path covered 19 kit
on the sample at the same time on the
same machine
keeping all the other conditions
consistent
and what we find you can see that the
n1 n2 we even performed the n3 target
which is not
which is not recommended and the sample
actually tested negative but with the
tac path
19 assay it tested positive
and we had it correlated with another
lab just so that
we're sure that it's not a false
positive and came back positive from
one of the other labs that we knew was
using
the the thermo fisher assay
and uh so this is what we have seen uh
you know with a lot of other
commercially available kits and that was
the reason why we
have you know uh consistently used
this kit was that the
the number of inconclusive results that
we get with the other assays is very
high
right so if we are running the n1 and n2
assay and the result is inconsistent
with the respect to only the n1 target
showing up or you know the the n2
not showing up or it's the n2 and not
the n1 showing up
and the result would be reported out as
inconsistent
i would say 100 of those instances
the attack path 19 kit gives us
an absolutely consistent result
where we can confidently call it either
positive or negative
so with that uh one of the things that
we're working on right now
is uh there is a massive influx of
samples
into the laboratory into our
laboratories right now
and what we are trying to do is uh
incorporate automation at all of our
levels
of our workflow and uh we are currently
trying to validate the 384
wealth format for the con studio 12k
also
uh in the meantime we are partnering
with a lot of local research groups
within the dfw area
and to test
the asymptomatic population for both
antibody serology testing and pcr
testing in parallel
and uh a paper will be coming out soon
with our collaboration with a group at
university of north texas where they're
looking at an experimental platform
using a paper spray mass spec and
in fact they they report a very high
correlation for our positive and
negative samples samples that were
provided to them
uh in a double blind fashion that
they are able to correlate them with
their experimental
methodology to 95 or higher
and uh another paper that we are coming
out very soon
is that we have been running a lot of uh
our samples
in parallel on our open array platform
for the respiratory panels and so we'll
be coming out
soon with uh our data on the
co-infection rates
or the bacterial and viral co-infection
rates of
covid19
so to summarize uh the
equipment 19 attack path assay has all
the hallmarks
of a good diagnostic test right it is
relevant
in this pandemic where the need now
is to have people resume
their economic and educational
activities in an
absolutely safe and reliable manner the
test is
rapid like i said 94 individual samples
with the multiplexing capabilities and
it is highly reliable i showed you the
data for the
high sensitivity and specificity of the
assay
and like i said before uh so the
the number in front of you it was
current as of uh
i would say 10 days ago
we have very reliably
and successfully tested the kit on
almost 220 000 different samples since
we launched the test
on 16th of march and
with that i would like to thank the
whole
infectious disease team here at
healthtrack rx
which has been working non-stop in
providing all these results out and uh
thanks to all of you for listening and
uh
i would hand it over to professor brooks
for his presentation
thank you
trouser brooks if you're speaking we
can't hear you maybe on me
i was thank you all right thank you
vijay um
what i was saying was that um vj and
lauren covered a lot of ground with
respect to kova 19. so
what i'd like to do is kind of describe
um what we've done with respect
to using the the techpath assay in our
eua which is really focused around
adding another biomaterial that we think
is an excellent source
for testing for kovid and this
innovation under pressure
quote actually was from the president of
the united states when he had announced
the eua that we had received for the
first saliva based test and
and to be honest we we can't take all of
the credit here in fact we picked the
smallest piece
because without an assay like tax
pathobig 19
um without extraction chemistries that
have been optimized and without
preservation agents and
really collection-based technologies the
only way to address supply chain issues
um what we focused on early in testing
was
getting patients to the test now we can
get tests to the patients with home
collection
is really where a lot of the innovation
comes from you know we're applications
people we put it together
um we built the process and we put it in
play
so we're not going to cover anything
other than
we all know a lot about source 2 v2
which causes kovac 19.
this is a molecular based approach not
an immuno immunological based approach
we actually are working on immunological
detection from
saliva not a topic for discussion today
but a concept where we can actually use
one biological sample to answer both
parts of the question
um we know a lot about coronaviruses
we're learning a lot more about sars
cov2
i'm not going to review a lot of this
but i think the one thing that i want to
point out with this slide is that
you know testing as a function of
detection
doesn't answer a lot of the questions
that we need to know about the virus and
vj's point with respect to why testing
now is even more important than a few
months ago
is that we've spent you know a lot of
our time
developing assays with 99 specificity
and sensitivity
on two percent of the population now we
need to look at what's really required
in looking at pooling approaches looking
at
creating more rapid or more efficient
pipelines or workflows
because we have to look at overall
sensitivity in
90 of the population which is a very
different
lab-based approach not to mention we
don't know
what the level of viral load is
responsible for
infection right or making people
infectious especially in the
asymptomatic population so
our ucdr is a next generation central
lab provider and diagnostic services
provider
we're a leader in in biobanking and
we're self-proclaimed biomaterial
experts and that's how we got to saliva
we have worked for 20-plus years in
helping pharma biotech academia
foreign governments u.s government
figure out what are the best
biomaterials to collect how do you best
preserve them
and how do you get the most out of them
so we were able to leverage
a lot of data not on on on covid 19 but
a lot of data
on what saliva can be used for how we
optimize with certain chemistries
um how we optimize that with qpcr to
get at the application of what we use
techpath4
um the other interesting thing is our
ucdr started as a grant contract
research organization we still are so
our ability to get to samples as well as
private sector
um and state and national level programs
to generate data was um something that
was really critical
and and one thing to keep in mind is
that our concept of managing the sample
life cycle
is is really critical here because again
you
look at just the assay in a bubble there
are lots of things you need to take into
consideration
the efficiency of collection the
stability of that sample the safety of
that sample then the process that
you know bj and lauren have talked about
and then the storage of that sample
after the fact
there are different environments that
actually could potentially lead to a
change in that sample
so as we start to develop you know all
of these biobanks around clovid19 to do
additional test development other
biomaterials
we really need to keep this this sample
life cycle in mind
the way we look at these things science
first process second
automation third this is a standard
process that we use in the lab
the difference here in our process is
we're using chemogene chemistry we've
also looked at
the um a thermo thermofisher chemistry
for extraction but this is what we had
in the lab
and we were looking for an assay and we
already were working on solutions for
collection and preservation
but i think the transition above this
dotted line of
manually processing samples using things
that you have in the lab eyeballing for
qc
doing some qc that's you know rather
blunt
is not going to get us to that high
throughput solution which are more
automated approaches
using tubes and plastics that are
automation friendly incorporating qc
tools
so that we can ultimately then go to
any biomaterial and be able to process
it and that's what we like about most b
based extraction chemistries is that
we can adjust them whether it's ph
whether it's lysis to be amenable to all
different kinds of biomaterials and this
is just a sampling of all the different
kinds of biomaterials we work with on
every day
everything from tear tears
to tissue to ffpe stool
the mesopharyngeal swab that you see
here and also with
with saliva and one thing that we need
to to keep in mind
is that what we're looking at now is
really unparalleled as everybody knows
imagine that some 350 million people in
the u.s in 2019 there were almost 130
million hospital visits
900 million doctors office visits and
the 13 billion diagnostic tests were
performed
less than 10 percent of those were
molecular analyses and if you look at
the scale and the scope of
people being tested multiple times if we
were to just collect
five different biomaterials or test
someone recurrently that's 4.4 billion
samples and imagine if you do that now
every year as we live with coronavirus
over an average lifespan of 15 years
that's 220 billion
samples so we know that molecular
samples will exceed the number of
paraffin blocks
just in tissue surgeries biopsies alone
but we need to incorporate that with
also
self-collected samples so if you look at
direct to consumer and the reason i'm
drawing this analogy here has to do with
saliva because a lot of these
applications
especially from where we made the
connection are at home or self
collection to be able to do this and
these numbers of samples are growing in
leaps and bounds now
everything is on on hold all of our
lives are on hold because of kovid
but this is something that we're going
to revisit as we look at the fall
with covid and influenza this is
something that we're going to have to
look at from a testing perspective where
all of those samples become relevant
lab automation innovation is also really
critical um
this was a collaboration and automation
collaboration that we did that allows us
in with an instrument the size of a new
york city
one bedroom apartment kitchen to do 10
000 extractions a day hands off
and this is the kind of work which takes
what lauren was taking to the next level
and she talks about additional
innovation for high throughput as we
start to screen large populations
certainly once we have you know a
blessing from the um
uh from the fda to do those kinds of
things
um this is the kind of innovation that's
that's needed and we're going to see
samples collected across
all different health care markets so
what we're seeing now
all of these different kinds of
companies
come up with covid based testing
approaches or at least for their
community
incorporating covid into the kinds of
tests that they do
so at home testing for kobit 19
until recently there was genealogy there
was entertainment through different apps
that you could have
in different place there's health or
risk assessment through 23andme and
ancestry's new healthcare platform
and now you know sadly we can add
infectious disease to this and even
though
there are immunological based tests that
people do um for infectious disease like
hiv from saliva and others
covid19 is going to come a regular part
of that regimen
now what's critically important in
biosample management and coded testing
are the three segments that are the same
for any
biomaterial sample collection and this
is my own personal opinion is where
false negatives come from
they don't come from the assay thermo
does an outstanding job in design and
silico
the the quality that they have and the
control as well as many other
manufacturers is outstanding
we rarely get a product that doesn't
meet that criteria however
what they can control for and what we're
responsible for
as the lab in this instance as a
clinical lab is making sure that sample
is collected properly that it's
processed and extracted properly and
that it's stored properly
because if any one of these things is
not done
properly and each has a different level
of variance that allows you to
still get a positive or a change that's
where we see when there are false
negatives even potentially false
positives
this is where the error comes from so
what we were looking for to build a
process
was to make sure we had the most robust
sample collection
so again for saliva for nasopharyngeal
swabs which are
um you know the the comparison here of
nasopharyngeal versus saliva
is for nasopharyngeal you have a
healthcare professional that's at risk
you know very close to your face
in taking the sample
you use a lot of ppe which is also
really limiting
and you're also limited by the surface
area of what's on the tip of that flock
swab
so granted where the nasopharyngeal
sample is taken from the virus loves to
live it's dark it's warm it's mucusy
outstanding but if you don't touch that
swab in the right place
or the surface area of that swab
depending on what you touch is limited
you are limited even though the sample
arguably could be potentially more
concentrated
when you look at collecting 2 mls of
saliva and on the right hand side is the
spectrum saliva collection device and
you spit to that line
you know two minutes you stood up to
that black line you screw the cap on the
blue preservation agent
drops down into the sample and now that
sample is stable for transport
safe um the virus is inactivated um
as well as uh the the rna preserved
that you're gonna more reproducibly be
able to spit into a tube
than somebody that's going and
necessarily taking a swab because also
there are differences in patient
um you know how the patient responds now
um
when we did this through the first
drive-throughs once we got our ela
approval
we went from a 7 a.m day to a 4 pm
collection day or 5 p.m collection day
um to a 7 a.m to 1 p.m collection day
and did
four times the number of samples and
reduced ppe by 90 percent
and those stayed in the hospitals where
they were belong for taking care of
patients
so the also the patient experience is
more robust and the collection and
reproducibility of collection is more
robust
we reduce the risk to medical personnel
we reduce the usage of ppe and we create
a robust mechanism now
when we talk about screening in our eua
a user goes through a quiz based
approach
a screening tool we work with a number
of telehealth partners
with a number of state
organizations people that are doing you
know their testing
you have to qualify a patient um to be
tested so these guidelines are
are constantly being developed and then
you have to have a scalable system to
support
any kind of broad testing and by
population testing i don't mean
population
screening so what we've done is we've
created a process that has a fail-safe
mechanism to ensure that the um that the
test is
um you know that the uh the test is
collected properly but it's also the
right person
so when you start to do home collection
as the fda explained to us as we went
through you know in
a collaborative manner and putting this
process together in our eua
authorization rather is that you want to
make sure it's the right person but also
the test is done in a safe manner that
if it's not done as indicated no one's
going to get hurt
and then also the sample stability
and safety so sample stability if you
give it to a carrier
we had to do temperature simulations
shipping simulations obviously
to be able to show that that sample
doesn't change in the context of
shipping
um one of our telehealth partners has a
very streamlined approach uh for getting
the kit you actually go on
a a zoom call and then
you um get your report well i know this
is small that you can't see it
and then the reporting to the state and
the regulatory authorities is is
automated which is also
a critical parameter for all labs uh
doing testing
because without the departments of
health and the federal government
seeing these results and understanding
it there's no way we're going to learn
what we need to to be able to control
and assess this pandemic
and as vijay was saying with sample
positives on the rise and we're seeing
alarmingly the same thing from very
different regions of the u.s where we're
testing now than
we've been dealing with primarily before
being a lab in new jersey
and and you know supporting new york new
jersey in the northeast
uh a very different approach so
um what happens in the laboratory i
think lauren covered that really well
you extract viral rna
uh in this case it's from from saliva
it's about a 40 minute procedure it's
all automated in that the saliva samples
are moved to the
plates that are used for extraction and
then liquid handlers are used to create
a 384 well format
we then use qpcr we love the concept of
three genes we can't tell you
how many times this has helped us
identify samples that would be
at the level of sensitivity for other
assays and giving us the confirmation
that a multiplex assay is reinforcing
the result that we are looking at
and then we look at the number of cycles
whether it's for ct or not
a thermo has a very simple to follow um
algorithm that helps us determine that
we validated that across samples so what
did our eua process look like
ours also like vj was describing was um
not a unique eua and that we didn't
create a brand new assay but we made
significant changes to the process
for us it was the chemistry by
perkinelmer
combined with the thermofisher assay
but that really wasn't as much of an
issue following the letter of the law
that would have mandated we go for our
edua
but it was really the addition of saliva
and using saliva as the primary
biomaterial
we did a whole number of
contrived samples that were were created
and what we submitted to the ua was that
but also a clinical study
as well so we looked at 60 subjects that
all had independently verified clinical
results so
we had sent their samples to another
reference lab blinded
to make sure that the results that we
got with saliva and mesopharyngeal swabs
was the same so these were all
symptomatic patients across three
different
they really weren't hospitals they were
ambulatory care facilities and what we
did at the same exact time
was have a patient spit into the the
spectrum saliva collection device
tap it up themselves you know shake it
for two seconds hand it back to the
healthcare professional
then that healthcare professional donned
and gowned um
and then took a nasopharyngeal swab or
an oral pharyngeal swab
from that patient at the same time both
of those samples were processed within
72 hours
at the same lab at our lab and to
compare mass to mass
because really it would be hard to look
at the surface area of the swab
versus the amount of saliva we use the
same volumes
so these np swab was put in 300
um in i'm sorry in three to three and a
half ml of utm
the saliva is 2ml of saliva and one and
a half ml of pressure of aging agent
so we're starting with the overall same
total volume we took the same amount of
volume 300 microliters of the saliva
solution 300 microliters of utm
extracted them in parallel and used five
microliters of the extraction product
for qpcr
so it's actually really unfair i didn't
um change this on the slide to call this
the old standard
you know the swabs are a standard and
they're they're an excellent way to test
um it's it's not about old versus new
it's about identifying a way to get
tests to people
and also increase the robustness of
testing so as
as you know from lauren's description
there's a spike in control
and what i just want to show here i'm
looking at the m gene the r1ab and the
mds
gene in positive samples that these are
five different patients that you can see
depending on their own infectious
journey
maybe at a lower viral load maybe at a
high viral load
and we've seen patients that are on
ventilators that have a lower viral load
than a patient that shows up
that's complaining they've lost their
their sense of taste so i think
understanding the clinical correlation
to viral load is something that we're
still learning a lot about
but from a testing perspective this
shows you that you can run the whole
gamut depending on the person that
you're collecting from and this is from
a swab
so these are selected samples just to
show you within a single set of
collections
how that variable can be and this also
demonstrates how clean this assay is
from across the room
you could call a positive versus a
negative now
if we look at saliva we saw the same
thing so here are the same five subjects
you can see that they all have a
different you know um
you know different ends of the spectrum
based on lower viral load
and the negative control data is exactly
the same and now if you look at
um positive and negative saliva positive
swab positive control negative control
you can see here in this summary again
with selected samples the positive
controls
are not at that lower end of the ct
values and that's a good thing because
you want that positive control to be
representative
of potentially what that assay you know
limit of sensitivity is
um whereas here are two examples of
samples that you know
are um uh you know a much higher viral
load
and again for the no template control
and your negative controls this all
checks out has been
very robust in the thermal assay but the
striking thing is
that if you look at the controls and the
actual samples you would expect to see a
difference
in you know your your controls
but if you look at the same five
subjects for swabs versus salivas
we see a distinct shift to the left
of just the fact that we think we have
more virus or a more robust collection
technique for those samples to show that
um saliva and again you're comparing two
different biomaterials so comparing
you know the viral load from each you
might expect a different results if
we're using the thermal assay
quantitatively now
um i know that it's not approved by
thermo for quantitation we're doing that
in our own lab and not in a clinical
setting but in a clinical trial setting
for looking at this but to show the
robustness of saliva collection and
processing
so if you look at the um at the data
summary um
very similar to what dj had shown you in
our contrived samples we had 100 percent
um correlation between positive and
negative in the
uh clinical samples we also had 100
percent
um so this was for nasopharyngeal
compared to saliva in the same patients
now this was in a very controlled
environment
and controlled setting up but we did see
100 agreement on swab and saliva results
and we also had a 100
positive agreement um in one to 2x lod
and in some instances could see very
low copies of samples now what i will
tell you
is that we've worked on some clinical
trials with
healthy populations and um
what we found is that in a population
that we have over a thousand people in a
clinical trial
where every two weeks we collect an np
and
a saliva sample that we see a 96
correlation between saliva and np and
these are in asymptomatic patients
um this is data we're working on
publishing and we're working on
submitting to the fda
as well uh and that four percent
difference is almost an even split
uh half of them 1.7
um are detected in np but missed in
saliva
and 2.3 percent are detected in saliva
missed np
and i think you're going to see a lot
more data in match studies that you know
can support this to show that they're
both high quality tests
both tests have to pass that certain you
know 96 97 percent
um you know a sensitivity if you will
and though and those by the way
were all patients that had low viral
load if you're looking at the overall ct
value associated with that these were
not
high viral load patients and as we
collect more people and learn more about
asymptomatic detection
i think what we're going to find and
again this is just my opinion
that tests that are qualified as you
know highly sensitive molecular tests
are going to hold true for detecting if
anybody
has that virus in any of these these
biomaterials so
we have a number of of um eu fda these
are not approvals they're authorizations
um that's my my bad uh for both swab and
saliva collection so we're using the
tacpap kit
in in saliva and all of the other
biomaterials that were on lauren's slide
and then we had an authorization um in
may
for um home collection of saliva which
is
really expanded the capacity for testing
for people that are
sick and don't want to go out that have
high risk where their doctors want them
tested that are just
afraid to go to areas where they want to
be collected
so it's become a huge advantage for
getting two people to the test
um we use a number of different swab
types um the
saliva collection device is the spectrum
device that's what's been validated in
the eua
um we're using an automated chemogene
chemistry for extraction like i said our
experience
with the thermochemistry is also
outstanding again because of our
development
and our the high throughput nature of
our lab this is what we had in place
the thermal fissure pack path kelvin 19
kit is critical for success so detection
on the end
um we wouldn't be where we are we
started with
um 384 uh well plates in the quant
studio and that was part of our
authorization
uh strictly because of the throughput
we've also gotten approval we're doing
testing in every state in the union but
there are certain states that require
specific licenses and approval
so we've done that we're testing across
a number of different applications
um like i said we're working on a saliva
based immunity test these are just
copies of our our existing eua
um and um that's
um you know something hopefully we'll be
telling you more about in the future
i had one additional slide but in the
interest of time it was kind of a
forward-thinking slide about
how you know personal biobanking is
going to affect covid and all these
other things
um happy to leave that as a part of the
deck if
thermo is going to circulate these and
i'm going to i'm going to stop there and
just thank everyone for their
for their attention
and thank all of you lauren dr singh dr
brooks
for your informative presentation and
your important research
we now are going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
audience members if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's take a look at the questions
already coming in
from our live audience and we have quite
a few
great questions can
the saliva test be used to detect
asymptomatic and pure symptomatic
subjects
so um you know my
again this is my opinion on this is that
the the test doesn't know if a person
has a fever
or if they've lost their sense of smell
or their sense of taste
um and what we believe and have faith in
is the sensitivity of the assay that's
authorized by you know our eua
to how many copies per ml we also don't
know a lot about the clinical
correlation associated with this
so what the appropriate level or
sensitivity is
to say that someone who's asymptomatic
is infectious
we don't know that or at least i don't
know that and these are some of the
things that are being worked through
but in a straight answer to your
question we have detected
covid19 in people that are asymptomatic
um as a part of research clinical trials
and other
um people that have been authorized or
medically approved for a test because of
close contact or exposure
and thank you for that similarly another
question about the saliva concerning the
use of saliva for coca-19 testing it was
shown that saliva samples of
some covid19 patients were either
negative or low positive
while the naso variegal
swaps of the same patients were positive
how are you planning to address this
issue
so i i'd have to look at that data um
again this goes back to the the the
false negative
um concerns that everyone has about any
test
we can say the same about patients that
test positive
for saliva and negative for
nasopharyngeal swabs
um you know early on people would
present because they were not feeling
well they would get a negative result
they would come back two days later and
say my conditions are worse
a little bit like the example of what dj
had said they're collected and they're
positive now i don't doubt
that they weren't positive two days
prior did
were they shedding in a virus
irrespective of the collection technique
that was at the level of sensitivity for
detection of the assay
you know that we don't know all i can
tell you is the paired studies that
we've done
um we've seen a very high correlation
between npop
and saliva um and and some of it also
has to do like i said with
the method of collection the experience
of the person collecting the
preservation agent
that's used for saliva collection so i
don't doubt that whoever asked that
question has seen data that says there's
a lack of correlation
but there's a lot more to look at to see
why that's the case and not just say
that saliva is not as good as mp
thank you for that now dr faki brought
up pool
testing or group testing being a
possibility
are you working on any form of this and
if not
what makes this method more effective
that is that question for me for andy
um i think it's open to whichever one of
you would like to answer it
i mean i can i can answer that to a
certain extent we have
uh looked at uh you know pooling
strategies and
uh again i the
the dilution that we had done on and the
data for which i had shown
was a part of that pooling strategy
also and uh you know
yes the concern would always be for the
really
low positive sample and uh
again a pooling strategy
would only work uh for the numbers that
we
saw in a 10 by 10 grid was uh
that the test would not be that
effective if we are looking at uh
a positive uh overall positive
percentage
of 10 or higher even 11
positive that's when the you have to go
ahead
and test all the samples in that pool
so yes if the
the disease positivity rate in the
population is
in our experience less than 11 that's
only when
uh any pooling strategy would be
effective i want to thank all three of
you i wish we had time for more
questions
today but i just want to remind our
audience members that any questions not
answered today
will be answered via annual to all of
you would you like to provide any
closing remarks
for our audience before we close
i would just like to thank everyone for
joining us we had over 1100 people
register
for the webinar all over the world so
whether it's with the thermo fisher
assay that's approved through cibd or
eua or some of the exciting new assays
that you're hearing from from both
vj as well as dr brooks we're very
excited to be in partnership with you
in fighting kobit 19. thank you for your
time
and again i want to thank all of you for
your time today and for your important
research
i'd also like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and laborats will
alert you via email when the webinar is
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
be safe bye